Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim.
Fridloff und das hier ist die 123.
Ausgabe von UKW. Und heute geht es mal nicht um die Ukraine,
nein, wir wollen das Brexit-Kapitel ein weiteres Mal und vielleicht auch zum
letzten Mal aufschlagen.
Und dafür begrüße ich natürlich John, John Worth, hallo.
Hallo wieder, ja.
Ja John, ist ein bisschen Zeit vergangen. Wir haben die letzte Sendung am 20.
Oktober 2022 veröffentlicht. Also ja, ein anderthalb Jahr mehr fast schon her.
Und das war ganz interessant. Wir haben uns in der Sendung ausführlich über
die furchtbare Zeit mit Boris Johnson und die dann irgendwie noch viel furchtbarere
Zeit von der Premierministerin Liz Truss unterhalten.
Und ihre aktuelle Regentschaft da komplett auseinandergenommen und sind mehr
oder weniger mit der Erwartungshaltung rausgegangen, dass das jetzt nicht mehr lange dauern kann.
Ich glaube, es war dann nur wie ein, zwei Stunden, nachdem ich die Sendung veröffentlicht
habe, kam dann auch bereits der Rücktritt.
Damit hat sie dann auf jeden Fall den Rekord für die kürzeste Regentschaft in
UK, glaube ich, gerissen.
Das ging dann mal sehr schnell.
Ja, und danach kam dann Rishi Sunak aus den Startlöchern und wurde dann von
den Tories zum neuen Premierminister gewählt.
Das ist so ein bisschen jetzt so der Punkt, an dem wir wieder aufsetzen können im Bay.
Wir haben ja dann auch noch den Tod der Queen erwähnt.
Naja gut, beklagt ist vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber zur Kenntnis genommen
und ja, mittlerweile heißt es nicht mehr God Save the Queen,
sondern God Save the King, denn der Sohn von Queen Elizabeth,
Charles, hat also jetzt den Thron bestiegen, ich weiß nicht,
hat das irgendwas gemacht mit Großbritannien, ist das irgendwie ein Ding, ist das wichtig?
Am Anfang haben wir alle ein bisschen so gedacht, das könnte etwas schwieriger
sein, weil der sei etwas so politischer als die Königin.
Aber das führte aus in den ersten paar Wochen zu keine großen Aufregungen.
Es gab natürlich viele Streitigkeiten innerhalb der königlichen Familie inzwischen.
Ja, und er ist selbst krank, Charles.
Also das bedeutet, es gibt keine große öffentliche Diskussion zu der königlichen
Familie, gerade in Großbritannien.
Also das spielt eine sehr untergeordnete Rolle.
Also ja, Alice ist zur Zeit und war in den letzten Monaten auch ziemlich ruhig.
Also diese große Aufregung rund um Kate, das ist jetzt inzwischen auch,
wird nicht in dem Alltag debattiert.
Die auch krank war.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich hatte nur so ein bisschen damit gerechnet, dass das sozusagen so eine mentale
Zeitenwende auslösen könnte, weil irgendwie diese ewige Regentschaft der Queen
steht ja im Prinzip auch für so eine Ära des,
der britischen Identität in gewisser Hinsicht.
Und wenn dann halt auf einmal sowas Signifikantes passiert, wie eben ihr Tod
nach all dieser langen Zeit, nach über 70 Jahren.
Ja, es ist eine sehr berechtigte Frage oder ein berechtigtes Punkt. Aber irgendwie.
Wir haben nur einfach so eine leere Periode gehabt in den letzten 18 Monaten.
Irgendwie Brexit ist vorbei, die Ära der Königin ist vorbei.
Wir wissen alle, dass die Ära der modernen konservativen Partei ist irgendwie auch vorbei.
Aber was kommt zunächst? Wir haben keine öffentliche Diskussion um die zukünftige
Richtung des Landes, der Regierung. Es ist einfach leer irgendwie gerade.
Und diese Diskussion, in welche Richtung geht das Land, hat nicht so wirklich begonnen.
Und auch während dieses Wahlkampf auch nicht so komplett begonnen.
Ja, also und das ist irgendwie sehr ungewöhnlich.
Britisches Politik war immer so sehr stark umstritten und während Boris Johnson
auch sehr stark umstritten.
Aber in den letzten 18 Monaten, es war so einfach alles, die Debatten fanden
statt, aber hatten kein Meaning irgendwie, ist ein bisschen so mein Eindruck.
Und keine große fundamentale Debatte zu der Rolle der königlichen Familie fand auch nicht statt.
Es ist eine sehr ungewöhnliche Periode, finde ich generell.
Also so eine Periode in meinem Leben habe ich bisher nicht gesehen oder nicht
erlebt, mit so einer gewissen Unklarheit über die Zukunft.
Also das Gesicht dieser Lehre ist natürlich dann damit Rishi Sunak,
der dann eben, wie ich schon angekündigt habe, dann Premierminister geworden ist.
Wer ist er und welche Rolle hat er vorher gespielt und welche Rolle hat er seitdem
gespielt, wenn überhaupt?
Ja, also wir haben dieses so Phrase im Englischen, to think without a trace,
wenn jemand so von einem Tag bis zum nächsten so verschwunden ist in der Politik.
Sunak ist irgendwie Heroes Without a Trace.
Der ist von nirgendwo so schnell auf die höchsten Ebenen des britischen politischen Systems gekommen,
dass niemand so wirklich verstanden hat, wofür steht er, warum ist er überhaupt da.
Er hat einen Hintergrund in dem Bankingsektor.
Er hat zusammen mit mir studiert in Oxford, aber ich habe keine Erinnerung von
dem Typen, überhaupt nicht.
Also wir waren in ganz unterschiedlichen politischen oder gesellschaftlichen
Ebenen als Studierenden. Er ist selber sehr reich.
Seine Frau ist ursprünglich aus Indien.
Er ist sehr, sehr reich. Also er kommt wirklich von der britischen wirtschaftlichen Elite.
Er war selber für den Brexit, also das ist dann ein Grund, warum er dann,
sag ich nicht beliebt war innerhalb von den Konservativen, aber zumindest eine
gewisse Unterstützung gekriegt hat.
Aber irgendwie, er ist ein ziemlich ruhiger Typ, aber er hat kein politisches
Gefühl, kein politisches Verständnis.
Wenn er redet mit Menschen, er kommt wie ein Banker rüber.
Er hat keinen Weg, als normales Mensch mit normaler Wähler umzugehen.
Und auch in seinen Medienauftritten ist er oft ziemlich robotisch.
Also das totale Gegenteil zu Boris Johnson zum Beispiel.
Ja genau, komplett im Gegenteil. Und er will tief in den Statistiken und in
den Zahlen blicken, was auch vollkommen richtig war als Finanzminister.
Das kann man vollkommen verstehen. Aber es ist ein bisschen,
wie wir das schon einmal erlebt haben mit Gordon Brown, der damalige Finanzminister unter Tony Blair.
Er ist später Premierminister geworden, aber dann war er erfolgreich als Finanzminister,
aber dann als Premierminister nicht.
Weil, also, die sind ganz unterschiedlichen Rollen. Aber ein Problem für die
Konservativen war, Moment mal, wer sonst haben wir?
Also, es standen keine andere Rolle.
Halbwegs qualifizierte Leute zur Verfügung innerhalb der Konservativen.
Also das bedeutet, es war schon nach ein paar Monaten seiner Amtszeit klar,
er hat Probleme als Premierminister, aber es gab schon im Frühling dieses Jahr
die Gerüchte, könnten die Tories
ihn dann schon ersetzen vor der Unterhauswahl, weil der sei so schwach.
Aber das Problem ist, wer käme dann sonst? Und das ist die Situation für ihn.
Er ist nicht korrupt, man merkt, wenn er lügt, was nicht der Fall war mit Boris Johnson,
aber er ist kein so Brückenbauer, er hat keinen guten Alliierten um sich innerhalb der Partei.
Also das bedeutet, die Lage für ihn war dann sehr schwierig von Beginn an.
Und er war dann innerhalb der Partei von Beginn an schwach, könnte die Situation
nicht ändern und die Tories hatten keine Alternative.
Also das war dann der Stand für ihn.
Ja, also man hat ihm glaube ich auch wirklich die ganze Zeit angemerkt,
diesen fehlenden Touch für die Gesellschaft und auch für den richtigen Moment.
Moment, das ist ein Höhepunkt und vielleicht auch sein größter Fehler war ja
jetzt bei den Feierlichkeiten zur Beendigung des Zweiten Weltkriegs.
Und wo halt alle Führer zusammenkamen, auch Selenskyj war ja vor Ort,
im Prinzip alle Alliierten waren vertreten, außer den Russen natürlich,
weil wissen wir ja, was da gerade abläuft.
Und Rishi Sunak war natürlich auch da, ist aber dann irgendwie zu dem finalen
Event schon abgereist gewesen,
um in irgendeinem Kindergarten irgendwie einen Werbespot für die anstehenden
Neuwahlen aufzunehmen.
Und irgendein Medienauftritt war es.
Also es war wirklich haarsträumend und die Kritik brach über ihn herein und
er musste sich dann glaube ich auch sofort entsprechend entschuldigen,
aber da war das natürlich dann alles zu spät, weil das war so im Prinzip der
Inbegriff der Fehleinschätzung.
Aber dieses politische Management fehlt total bei den Konservativen gerade.
Die hatten das auch zu Boris Johnsons Zeiten immer im Griff.
Also dieses politische Theater, diese Präsentation, Medienmanagement,
das haben die Konservativen seit Jahrzehnten.
Ziemlich gut im Griff. Das haben die gerade nicht.
Also was für Berater hat dann Hatsunag, damit man so einen Fehler macht?
Und wir haben auch gerade gehört, dass es gab einen Streit zwischen ihm und
dem Hauptberater, Levido heißt er, war es eine gute Idee,
so diesen frühen Unterhauswahl zu machen, jetzt im Juli, statt bis Oktober zu warten.
Also wir wissen, dass irgendwas stimmt nicht zwischen Sunak und seiner eigenen Berater gerade.
Und das war ein Beweis davon, dieses Skandal um den Dings in den Nummern,
die so den Fall zu dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges.
Wir wollten ja diese Sendung eigentlich ein bisschen früher machen,
wir hatten ja ursprünglich gesagt, naja, wir machen mal wieder eine,
wenn dann die Wahlen kommen und dann kamen die Wahlen dann doch sehr überraschend,
sodass wir jetzt tatsächlich am Vorabend der Wahl, am 4.
Juli, hier, also heute ist der 3.
Juli und ich werde zusehen, dass die Sendung noch schnell vor der Wahl rauskommt,
dann können unsere Predictions hier vielleicht auch noch greifen,
aber ja, das kam halt sehr überraschend. Aber runden wir das vielleicht nochmal ab.
Also Sunak kam an die Macht, hatte aber eigentlich keine, aber es gab auch keine
Alternative, weil ich habe so das Gefühl, dieser Prozess des Ausblutens von innen heraus,
der Tories, der findet jetzt sozusagen seinen Abschluss.
Also man dachte ja schon die ganze Zeit, Leute, was habt ihr für Personal und
ihr habt keine Vision und ihr kriegt nichts auf die Kette und der Brexit war
ein großer Fehler und keiner ist bereit, das zuzugeben und ihr habt den rechten Rand nicht im Griff,
ihr habt sozusagen die Mitte nicht mehr für euch und ihr habt auch keine klare
Vision und es geht die ganze Zeit hin und her.
Und man merkt es schon richtig von außen, wie so ein bisschen auch der Geduldsfaden
der britischen Bevölkerung, die ja eigentlich generell immer sehr konservativ ist.
Ich meine, wie lange waren die jetzt an der Macht? Zwölf, vierzehn, sechzehn Jahre?
Ja, vierzehn Jahre diesmal. Genau.
Und ich glaube, selbst die härtesten Tory-Verfechter haben Schwierigkeiten,
entweder sich selbst oder andere Leute zu motivieren, jetzt überhaupt noch zur Wahl zu gehen.
Aber es gibt natürlich, die haben Probleme auf beiden Seiten.
Also es gibt diese besonders im Südosten Englands, also nicht in London, aber so drumherum.
Also es heißt Home Counties, also die Vororte von London und auf dem Land im Südosten.
Das sind so die Tory-Heartlands, wo die Tories gewonnen haben seit Jahrzehnten.
Aber da ist es ziemlich reich, halbwegs weltoffen.
Und da ist das Gefahr, dass die verlieren da gegen die Liberalen.
Also das sind wirklich so alte Tory-Städte.
Und dann im Norden, die haben dieses Problem. Das sind die Orten,
wo Boris Johnson erstaunlicherweise gewonnen hat in 2019. Hat da hauptsächlich
gegen Labour damals gewonnen.
Und die Frage ist, haben die Konservativen ausreichend Unterstützung in dieser
Art von Städten, dann einfach nochmal gegen Labour zu gewinnen,
also diese Wahlsiege von Boris Johnson zu verteidigen.
Und die Antwort auf beiden Seiten ist hauptsächlich Nein.
Und das ist dann auch eine Frage, also wie haben wir dann dieses Punkt erreicht?
Also wir gehen zuerst zu den politischen Entscheidungen von Rishi Sunak, weil er hat versucht,
diese sehr harte Linie gegen die Einwanderung von Boris Johnson weiterhin zu verschärfen.
Einfach mal diese rechte Seite, also die rechten Populisten von Nigel Farage,
einfach mal sich gegen diese rechten Splitter-Bewegung zu verteidigen.
Und das führte zu dieser absurden Situation,
die Abschiebung von Asylbewerbern, wenn die dann eine Ablehnung gekriegt haben,
die nach Rwanda wegzuschieben.
Das war keine funktionierende Politik, weil die Anzahl an Leuten,
die man so abschieben könnte, war so sehr gering.
Es war von allen kritisiert, wenn nicht aus ethischen Gründen,
dann aus Kostengründen schärf kritisiert.
Und Sunak, man hat so den Eindruck, er glaubte selber nicht an diese Politik.
Musste trotzdem das dann machen, weil er war so vorangetrieben von dem rechten
Flügel auf seine eigene Partei.
Und das führte so diese absurden Diskussionen in den Unterhaus,
wo man hat den Eindruck, die Konzeptteam haben das getan, obwohl die wussten
selber, dass es nicht funktioniere.
Und irgendwie, wenn wir blicken zurück auf den 18 Monaten Amtszeit von Rishi
Sunak, Das ist das hauptsächliche Politik von ihm,
wo er dann wirklich viel politisches Zeitengagement da reingesteckt hat.
Und er hat auch eine andere ungewöhnliche Politik zu stärkere Regeln gegen Rauchen.
Also ein Verbot von dem Verkauf von Zigaretten an junge Leute.
Er hat versucht, das durchdurchzukämpfen.
Auch ohne großes Erfolg.
Und wofür steht er?
Wofür stehen die Konservativen gerade? Das ist eine sehr leere Hülle geworden
als Partei in den letzten 18 Monaten, weil Sunak hat selber keine Richtung.
Die Partei weiß selber nicht, in welche Richtung man gehen soll.
Es ist je nach Person oder je nach Region unterschiedlich. Und das erklärt die jetzige Lage.
Natürlich, man kann gar nichts über Brexit sagen, weil die Konservativen sind
de facto so die Pro-Brexit-Partei geworden.
Also auch in den kleinsten Details, man darf Brexit nicht erwähnen.
Und das erklärt ein bisschen diese sehr schwierige Situation für Sunak.
Don't mention the war.
Don't mention the Brexit.
Okay, das gibt uns vielleicht mal die Gelegenheit, mal so auf die wirtschaftliche
Situation von UK einzugehen.
Also was ist denn jetzt sozusagen die Auswirkung?
Jetzt haben wir ja wirklich genug Zeit gehabt.
Brexit ist jetzt irgendwie seit vier Jahren auch offiziell in place und es gab
halt alle möglichen Nachverhandlungen.
Ja, aber da ist es auch sehr interessant. Inwiefern werden Lebensmittelprodukte
kontrolliert bei der Einreise in Großbritannien?
Also die haben doch noch nicht die kompletten Kontrollen eingeführt,
weil die haben immer noch nicht ausreichend Zollpersonal, um das überhaupt zu machen.
Also das führte dann zu dieser absurden Situation, dass die Kontrollen auf Lebensmitteln
bei der Ausreise aus Großbritannien strenger waren als bei der Einreise.
Und dass es, Moment mal, so Take Back Control war, also wir wollen alles an
unserer Grenze kontrollieren können, tun wir aber nicht, weil wir haben nicht
genug Leute rekrutiert, um das überhaupt zu machen.
Also ein bisschen absurd. Aber natürlich eine so tiefgehende Verhandlung mit
Brüssel war nicht möglich, weil das war von dann zu lang nicht gewollt.
Also es gab nur in ein kleines Politikfeld einen kleinen Schritt nach vorn.
Das war, dass britische Universitäten durften wieder in den Horizon-Programmen,
also die Rechercheprogrammen der Europäischen Union, wieder dabei sein.
Also das war ein kleines Schritt nach vorn.
Forschung, also wissenschaftliche Forschung.
Und es gab dann auch ein kleines Schritt nach vorne bezüglich Nordirland und
ein Deal mit Brüssel im Februar dieses Jahr und das hat die Situation da ein bisschen beruhigt.
Aber grundsätzlich, dann wirtschaftlich, es gibt diese großen Fragezeichen,
also wenn man schaut in den Zahlen, das ist ein großes Problem für die britische Wirtschaft noch,
ist wie sehen die Verhältnisse mit Brüssel aus mittelfristig und das ist ein
wirtschaftliches Last für Großbritannien,
das Großbritannien nicht in der Europäischen Union ist.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, es gibt keine tiefgehende wirtschaftliche Krise.
Arbeitslosigkeit ist nicht deutlich höher gestiegen.
Es ist, man sieht, dass die wirtschaftliche Situation ist in Ordnung.
Das Problem ist bei den staatlichen Finanzen.
Also eine zukünftige Regierung hat ein Problem,
dass man hat die staatlichen Finanzen so reduziert während dieser Periode der Konservativen,
dass es gibt dann finanzielle Krisen in diversen Sektoren, aber öffentliche
Sektoren, also Universitäten stecken in einer finanziellen Krise,
Städten, also die Stadt Birmingham,
also die Regierung von der Stadt ist offiziell pleite.
Zeit in Großbritannien, weil man hat die Steuereinnahmen so reduziert, dass die.
Diese diversen Teilen des Staates befinden sich gerade in einer Krise.
Es gibt eine Rekrutierungskrise in dem kompletten Bildungssystem, in den Schulen.
Das bedeutet, dass die wirtschaftliche Lage insgesamt, also Wirtschaftswachstum,
die Prozentzahl der Arbeitslosigkeit, all das ist halbwegs in Ordnung.
Das Problem liegt bei den Staatseinnahmen und Ausgaben.
Also das ist gerade die Situation.
Also wenn Labour jetzt den Unterhaltswahl gewinnt, die befinden sich in einer
Situation, wo es kein großes Wirtschaftswachstum gibt.
Aber die hauptsächlichen Probleme sind in dem öffentlichen Sektor,
so an Einkommen und Ausgaben des Staates.
Also das ist grob die jetzige Situation.
Aber die Lebensmittelpreise, habe ich so das Gefühl, sind schon stark gestiegen in Großbritannien.
Ja, aber irgendwie, und auch es gab Probleme mit den Lieferketten,
weil die Anzahl an Lieferanten nach Großbritannien ist gesunken seit dem Brexit.
Also nicht alle Firmen liefern noch nach Großbritannien. Also ja,
aber Inflation ist etwas höher als in anderen Ländern der EU,
aber die Situation ist etwas entspannter geworden in den letzten Monaten.
Aber nicht genug, damit die Konservativen sagen, ja alles sei in Ordnung. Ja.
Also nichts bewegt sich so richtig voran, aber es ist halt auch noch nicht in
so eine totale Krise ausgeartet.
Aber man merkt natürlich schon auch, dass die Rolle, also ich meine klar,
Großbritannien spielt jetzt sozusagen in Europa keine Rolle mehr,
während aber Europa immer eine größere Rolle spielt.
Ich denke, da lohnt es sich vielleicht auch nochmal auf die Situation mit dem
Ukraine-Krieg zu schauen.
Das wiederum finde ich ganz interessant, weil sich ja hier schon Boris Johnson
und auch Rishi Sunak jetzt in der Folge relativ klar, sag ich mal,
in so eine britische Tradition einer...
Ich weiß nicht, ob Weltmacht das richtige Wort ist, aber eines signifikanten
Teils des internationalen Sicherheitssystems gestellt hat.
Es war von vornherein klar, wie man sich da positioniert.
Man war auch immer einen Schritt weiter, nicht nur als die EU,
sondern eigentlich auch als die USA.
Also in gewisser Hinsicht würde ich fast sagen, unter all den Unterstützerstaaten
nimmt UK eher den Platz 1 ein.
Zumindest was das Politische betrifft, was jetzt so finanzielles,
Waffenlieferungen usw.
Im Einzelnen betrifft, das weiß ich gar nicht, ob man das so ohne weiteres zusammenrechnen
kann, aber es war halt recht klar und eigentlich auch zu keinem Zeitpunkt im
Zweifel, egal wer die Regierung jetzt angeführt hat,
dass sich da Großbritannien halt klar stellt.
Und das fand ich insofern beruhigend und auch,
ich weiß nicht, ob überraschend das richtige Wort ist, aber ich hatte schon
befürchtet, dass diese russische gesellschaftliche Infiltration auch in London
eine große Rolle spielt,
weil ja auch die Russen dort eine ganze Menge Geld geparkt haben und so weiter.
Und ich hatte schon so die Befürchtung, meine Herren, wenn die jetzt da auch
noch alle gekauft sind, dann wird es aber schwierig.
Aber ich glaube an der Stelle setzt sich dann doch eher diese britische Seele durch.
Da ist man dann doch wieder so die Weltmacht und lässt sich da nicht groß reinreden.
Und man muss auch sagen, ein bisschen härter gegen russisches Geld in Großbritannien,
das begann schon unter Theresa May ein bisschen.
Also so ein Höhepunkt, so russisches Geld aus Russland in Großbritannien,
das war jetzt etwas länger her. Ja, natürlich.
Also das ist dann auch ein Gefahr. Also es gibt gerade Gerüchte,
dass die Russen finanzieren diese so rechtspopulistische Bewegung von Nigel
Farage und dass das Geld aus Russland da eine Rolle spielt.
Aber ziemlich grundsätzlich dieses...
Inwiefern es eine Diskussion gibt, über was ist die Rolle Großbritanniens seit
dem Brexit, ist ein bisschen so diese Brücke zwischen Vereinigten Staaten und Europa.
Ob die Vereinigten Staaten und Europa das wirklich so verstehen,
bin ich nicht sicher, aber Großbritannien hat versucht, so geopolitisch ein
bisschen diese Rolle zu spielen, besonders bezüglich der Kriege in der Ukraine.
Und das wird so weitergehen, auch unter einer neuen Regierung.
Es herrschen in Großbritannien einige Fragen,
dass die, zum Beispiel, haben die Konservativen das britische Militär ausreichend finanziert,
weil die haben die Finanzierung des ganzen Militärsystems in Großbritannien
auch unter Druck gesetzt.
Also die Konservativen sind so traditionell, also die Partei der Armed Forces
in Großbritannien, aber die haben auch da die Finanzierung reduziert.
Also da gibt es ein großes Fragezeichen für die zukünftige Regierung.
Nicht inwiefern man soll die Ukraine weiterhin unterstützen,
aber wie soll die britische Militär generell in den nächsten Jahrzehnten dann auch aussehen.
Das wird natürlich jetzt auch nochmal interessant im Hinblick auf die Wahlen in den USA.
Wir haben ja schon in der EU die Debatte mit, okay, was ist,
wenn uns jetzt nochmal eine Trump-Regierung droht und dann die NATO im Prinzip in Frage gestellt wird,
beziehungsweise dieser US-Beistand in Frage gestellt wird.
Das wird natürlich alle vor größte Probleme stellen, wenn das so käme,
was ich nicht hoffe, aber who knows. Ähm, und ich glaube,
dass das sicherlich in UK auch eine große Frage ist, oder? Also insbesondere,
wenn man jetzt damit rechnen kann.
Dass es mit Labour kommt. Aber irgendwie,
diese außenpolitischen Fragen haben keine große Rolle gespielt in dieses,
Wahlkampf, weil die beiden großen Parteien sind hauptsächlich pro NATO,
wollen Wollen gute Beziehungen mit den Vereinigten Staaten und wollten sich
nie so wirklich die Frage, was sollen wir tun, falls Donald Trump gewinnt.
Also diese Frage, soweit ich das erlebt habe und ich folge jeden Tag die Nachrichten
zu diesem Wahlkampf, das taugte nicht so wirklich auf.
Also in der Öffentlichkeit, glaube ich, ist das noch kein Thema und das ist
bei uns, glaube ich, auch noch nicht so richtig der Fall.
Aber ich denke, dass das definitiv ein heißes Thema in den politischen Eliten ist.
Und insbesondere, wenn man sich jetzt quasi auf Regierungsübernahme einstellt,
dann ist ja auch die Frage, wie richtet man dann eine neue Regierung aus.
Ich habe, obwohl Großbritannien tut ja was für die Ukraine, dieses Wahlkampf ist gerade sehr...
Innenblickend. Was tun wir unsere eigene so irgendwie reduzierte Rolle irgendwie,
was machen wir selber irgendwie?
Es ist sehr so self-referential irgendwie, dieses Wahlkampf gerade.
Vielleicht nochmal ein Blick auf das Brexit- Thema. Also mich würde auch nochmal
konkret interessieren, wie diese Nordirland-Regelung jetzt aussieht,
aber vor allem auch Auch, wie wird jetzt der Brexit gesehen?
Also klar, die Tories, für die ist das eine heiße Kartoffel, keine Frage.
Aber ich habe so den Eindruck gewonnen von so Medienberichten etc.,
dass jetzt in zunehmendem Maße, vor allem aus der Wirtschaft heraus,
schon klarere Statements zu hören sind, als man das vor ein,
zwei, drei Jahren noch hatte.
Viele mögen das nicht thematisiert haben wollen, Weil das politisch nicht irgendwie angesagt war.
Andere hatten vielleicht durchaus noch diese Glauben an die Versprechungen,
dass dadurch alles besser wird.
Aber viele sind ja jetzt quasi mit dieser Red-Tape-Problematik,
also dass es immer mehr neue Regeln gibt für Import und Export,
mithin zu dieser Konsequenz, dass man seine Partner in der EU nicht aufrechterhalten
kann oder selber in die EU gehen muss, um überhaupt noch mitspielen zu dürfen.
Das scheint mir jetzt schon doch eine größere Rolle zu spielen.
Also wie siehst du so die Reaktion auf das Wort Brexit? Sind die Leute jetzt
bereit darüber zu reden?
Wenn man schaut in den Meinungsumfragen, war Brexit die richtige Entscheidung oder nicht? Also...
Nicht mit Bezug auf den Unterhauswahl, sondern einfach nur für sich.
Das Bewirkung fragen, war Brexit die richtige Entscheidung?
Da sieht man stabile Mehrheiten für, nein, das war die falsche Entscheidung.
Also das bedeutet, das hat nicht so viele Vorteile gebracht,
hat die Mehrheiten der Bewirkung jetzt verstanden.
Also eigentlich gar keine Vorteile, oder?
Ja, genau. Es gibt natürlich dieses Argument von Nigel Farage.
Ja, es liegt nicht an Brexit, sondern das war einfach nur miserabel durchgeführt.
Also irgendwie, das war nicht revolutionär genug irgendwie. Und das kommt ein
bisschen in die öffentliche Diskussion.
Das lag an den Tories, die waren nicht fähig. Aber das ist keine mehrheitliche Position.
Das ist einfach, dass Brexit selber was schuld. Es lag nicht an der falschen Ausführung.
Die Situation hat sich auch in Nordirland ein bisschen beruhigt.
Die haben das irgendwie so pragmatisch geklärt, dass es keine Kontrollen gibt
zwischen Nordirland und Irland.
Faktisch, die Grenze ist zwischen Nordirland und dem Rest von Großbritannien,
aber die haben das politisch abgedeckt,
dass Nordirland ein Kernteil von Großbritannien ist,
um dann den Democratic Unionist Party zu beruhigen.
Und irgendwie diese Spannungen um Lebensmittelkontrollen, die Situation hat
sich generell da beruhigt, weil Großbritannien auch nicht in der Lage ist,
in Nindova zu kontrollieren.
Also grob die Situation, niemand will hier gerade ein großes Streit.
Und ich habe auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck inzwischen gekriegt,
dass die Democratic Unionist Party verstanden hat, hey Moment mal,
es wird eine neue Regierung geben in London,
lass uns mal ruhig bleiben kurzfristig und sehen wir mal dann danach,
wie alles dann aussieht.
Aber ich finde dieses Deal im Februar dieses Jahr dann sehr pragmatisch.
Also es besteht, das zweite Vorgehen faktisch ist keine Grenze zwischen Nordirland
und Irland, aber politisch, die haben ein bisschen so Abdeckung gekriegt von London aus,
dass Nordirland bleibt ein wichtiges Teil von Großbritannien und so sah dem Deal aus.
Also gibt es jetzt keine Kontrollen?
Ja, also die gehen, die haben dieses neue Office etabliert.
Dieses Office soll dann gucken, durch den alltäglichen pragmatischen,
problematischen Situationen so durcharbeiten.
Damit, falls irgendwas nicht stimmt,
dieses Office greift ein, um zu gucken, können wir das irgendwie erleichtern,
dass manche Produkte nicht lieferbar nach Nordirland sind und man keine Zollkontrollen braucht.
Sie heißt InterTrade UK, dieses Gremium, um die alltäglichen Schwierigkeiten zu reduzieren.
Ein praktisches und politisches Kompromiss, damit es alles nicht schwieriger wird.
Wird das in den Alltag helfen? Ich weiß nicht.
Aber es ist ein cleveres Kompromiss, muss man sagen.
Also es ist so ein bisschen ein, wir wollen jetzt Ruhe haben,
sowohl von UK-Seite als auch von EU-Seite.
Nach dem Motto, wir haben einfach keinen Bock mehr, uns hier groß zu streiten.
Zu dem Punkt zu streiten. Okay, verstehe. Und da auch, ja, also Nordirland ist
kein wichtiges Thema für Sunak.
Er schaut in den wirtschaftlichen Zahlen und aus dem Punkt will er Lösungen finden.
Er wird keine große Rede halten wie Theresa May, die Einigkeit Großbritanniens oder so.
Also Theresa May glaubte wirklich
an die so Union, United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland.
Also das spielt für Sunak keine große Rolle.
Schauen wir nochmal kurz, wenn wir eh schon bei Nordirland sind,
da auch auf die politische Situation.
Es gab ja Wahlen und wir haben immer das Problem,
dass dort ja auf Basis der Freitagsfriedensregelung immer so eine Shared Power
sein muss zwischen Unionisten und Nationalisten.
Trotzdem war es bisher immer so, dass bei den Wahlen die DUP,
also die Unionisten, mehr oder weniger die Mehrheit hatten.
Das ist jetzt bei der letzten Wahl das erste Mal gekippt.
Sinn Fane hatte die Mehrheit und dementsprechend ist jetzt auch eine Vertreterin,
Michelle O'Neill heißt sie glaube ich, ist jetzt sozusagen First Minister geworden.
Hat denn Nordirland derzeit einfach
eine funktionierende Regierung oder blockiert sich das alles wieder?
Macht das überhaupt irgendeinen Unterschied und welche Rolle spielt das sozusagen?
Das ist ziemlich ruhig inzwischen.
Die Situation war ziemlich entspannt.
Es war auch irgendwie hilfreich, dass die DUP, also die hauptunionistische Partei,
interne Schwierigkeiten hatte.
Weil es gibt so Sexualbelästigungsvorwürfe gegen den Parteichef.
Also das bedeutet, dass die haben so untereinander gestritten,
statt es führte dann zu keinem großen Kampf in Richtung Sinn fein.
Also die Situation ist...
War auch in den letzten Monaten ziemlich entspannt, also zumindest in die öffentliche Diskussion.
Ja, okay. Wo wir dann bei Nordirland sind, müssen wir vielleicht auch nochmal
kurz auf Schottland schauen.
Wir hatten ja dort immer wieder diese permanente Auseinandersetzung um dieses
mögliche neue Referendum,
nachdem ja kurz vor dem Brexit ein Referendum knapp gescheitert war,
dass Schottland gegebenenfalls aus der Union austritt.
Dann wurde ewig dieses Thema mit, jetzt müssen wir aber nochmal abstimmen.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, zwei große Sachen sind passiert.
Einerseits hat der Supreme Court in UK eine Entscheidung gefällt und meint,
ein neues Referendum so wird es nicht geben oder darf es nicht geben.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was genau die Aussage war.
Ja, also man braucht ein Gesetz in London, damit so ein Referendum stattfinden könnte.
Das Problem war, das kam nicht zustande wegen Regierungsproblemen in Schottland
selber. Also seit Anfang 2023.
Also Nicola Sturgeon kundigte 2023 seinen Rücktritt an,
gab es parteiinterne Skandale bei den schottischen Nationalisten und der Mann
von Nicola Sturgeon war selber beteiligt.
Das Problem war, innerhalb der schottischen Nationalisten gab es so diversen
Flügeln zu anderen politischen Themen, also nicht die politische Unabhängigkeit Schottlands,
sondern was für politische Positionen, wofür steht die SNP überhaupt?
Haut, weil wenn ein Referendum nicht möglich ist, kurz bis mittelfristig,
wofür steht die Partei gerade? Und die haben dann,
Hamza Yusuf als Parteichef der schottischen Nationalisten und dann auch als
Premierminister Schottlands gewählt, 2023.
Er war mehr von den, sage ich, linksliberalen Flügeln der schottischen Nationalisten.
Aber dann, es gab eine Krise, weil die regierten nicht alleine in die schottische
Regierung, sondern nur mit der Unterstützung der Grünen zusammen.
Und dann dieses Regierungsstil von Hamza Yusuf war dann problematisch.
Die Grünen sagen, hey Moment mal, wir vertrauen dir die Regierung von Yusuf
nicht mehr, wir steigen aus.
Es drohte dann Neuwahlen, stattdessen ist Yusuf dann zurückgetreten und dann
John Swinney ist jetzt Parteichef und Premierminister von Schottland geworden.
Und der ist mehr auf der so Nicola Sturgeon-Linie.
Wir halten diese Bewegung zusammen,
damit wir hauptsächlich für einen unabhängigen Schottland kämpfen.
Und das führte in den letzten Wochen zu einer etwas besseren Situation für die
schottischen Nationalisten in den Meinungsumfragen.
Also die Situation ist dann, es gab keine ernsthaften Diskussionen in Schottland
in den letzten 12 bis 18 Monaten zu, wie organisieren wir erneut eine Volksabstimmung,
weil es gab diese interne Streitereien innerhalb der schottischen Nationalisten.
Aber die Situation mit John Swinney jetzt hat sich beruhigt.
Er ist ein eher konsensualer Typ, eher ruhiger als Yusuf.
Also diese Situation ist, die Spannung hat sich reduziert.
Aber diese Frage wird nicht weggehen,
weil Labour kämpft gegen die
schottischen Nationalisten, gerade bei der Unterhauswahl in Schottland.
Und diese Frage bleibt dann ungelöst.
Aber zurzeit, ich halte kein zweites Referendum in Schottland für möglich in
den nächsten paar Jahren.
Wir werden mal sehen, wie es aussehen wird zwischen London und Schottland in den nächsten Jahren.
In den nächsten paar Jahren. Aber niemand stellt sich gerade ernsthaft die Frage,
wann wird so ein zweites schottisches oder erneut ein Referendum stattfinden in Schottland.
Das wird dann sicherlich auch sehr davon abhängen, wie Labour in Schottland
jetzt bei den Wahlen abschneidet, weil traditionell haben sie ja durchaus die Möglichkeit,
da ein paar Sitze wieder zu gewinnen und das war ja in den letzten Jahren alles
so überlagert von der Anti-Tory-Stimmung und auch der Anti-Labour-Stimmung,
dass eben SNP da so anziehen konnte, von daher rechne ich da eher mit ein bisschen,
ja, da werden sich die Kräfte ausdrücken.
Leiber wird bestimmt 15 oder 20 Sitze in Schottland gewinnen,
die S&P dann mehr verlieren.
Also die Situation wird dann entsprechend schwächer für die schottischen Nationalisten
nach der Unterhauswahl.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch mal genau auf diese Wahl. Also wir haben ja jetzt schon
über die Tories gesprochen, da sieht es halt nicht gut aus.
Rishi Sunak tritt trotzdem halt an und niemand geht derzeit eigentlich davon
aus, dass die Tories irgendeinen Blumentopf gewinnen können.
Ich habe sogar schon, du hast ja schon angedeutet, auch im Süden,
wo es traditionell eigentlich immer stabil war für die Tories, drohen Sitzverluste.
Ich glaube sogar Jacob Rees-Mogg ist in Gefahr, seinen Sitz zu verlieren.
Ja, Michael Gove, Jeremy Hunt, also diese bekannten alten Herren der Tories können alle verlieren.
Das heißt, es könnte durchaus sein, dass so ein Teil der ganzen Pro-Brexit-Garde
komplett von der Bildfläche verschwindet.
Ja, aber grob, also wie ist diese Situation zustande gekommen überhaupt?
Also weil man muss eine Unterhauswahl innerhalb von fünf Jahren organisieren,
also in fünf Jahren nach dem Amtsbeginn des neu gewählten Unterhauses.
Also das bedeutet, dass der letzte mögliche Termin für eine Unterhauswahl wäre dann Januar 2025.
Niemand hat so gedacht, man will eine Unterhauswahl mitten im Winter machen,
wie Boris Johnson das mal getan hat 2019.
Also alle haben gedacht, okay, Sunak wird das im Herbst 2024 dann machen.
Er hatte keine große Hoffnung, aber einfach mal, okay, wir warten mal ein bisschen,
vielleicht kommt irgendwas zustande, was uns dann irgendwie hilft.
Stattdessen hat er es dann vor dem Sommer gezogen, findet dann diese Woche statt
und nichts hat sich inzwischen geändert,
um die Lage für Sunak zu verbessern.
Also es droht dann für die Konservativen enorme Verluste, nicht unbedingt weil
Labour besonders stark ist, sondern weil die Tories so verdammt schwach sind
und verlieren in ziemlich alle Richtungen an Unterstützung.
Also die werden in Industriestädten und im Norden Englands Sitze an Labour verlieren,
im Süden Englands und im Südwesten sitzen an die Liberalen verlieren und in
ein paar Orten auch werden die dann auch sitzen an dieser Reformbewegung von
Nigel Farage auch dann Sitze verlieren.
Und das Ding ist, wenn so dieses Mitte-bis-Rechts-Lager in zwei verteilt ist, das hilft Labour enorm.
Weil wenn in einem Wahlkreis Reformen gewinnt nur 10% abgegeben Stimmen,
die Konservativen dann 20%, aber Labour gewinnt dann 25%, die gewinnen dann
im Sitz im Unterhaus mit nur 25% abgegeben Stimmen.
Also das bedeutet, dass diese Verteilung in zwei auf der rechten Seite des politischen
Spektrums macht die Situation dann deutlich schwieriger für die Konservativen
und es droht dann enorme Sitzverluste.
Also alle Meinungsumfragen gehen davon aus,
dass die Konservativen werden auf einer geringeren Anzahl an Sitzen landen diesmal
als bei der Unterhauswahl 1997,
als Tony Blair damals gewann.
Und das Labour, alle gehen davon aus, das Labour werden dann eine größere Mehrheit
bekommen, als Tony Blair damals gekriegt hat.
Also das sind historische Verluste für die Konservativen.
Also in den Meinungsumfragen gibt es so Schwankungen von einem Gewinn, den...
Bei einer Höchstzahl an Sitzen für die Konservativen, bei nur 170 Sitzen und
die sind bei jetzt über 260.
Und in manchen Meinungsumfragen landen die bei so wenig wie 53 Sitzen.
Und dann könnten sogar von den Liberalen überholt werden, nicht an den Prozentzahl
der Abgebensstimmen, sondern an die Prozentzahl der Sitzen im Unterhaus.
Also es drohen da enorme Verluste für die Konservativen. Also das ist die Situation.
Und man muss auch sagen, das ist im Vergleich zu der Situation im Jahr 97,
es ist nicht, dass Labour irgendwie sehr gut ist,
sondern dass die Konservativen so enorme Schwierigkeiten haben.
Es ist nicht unbedingt, dass Labour unter Kirstein so sehr überzeugend ist,
aber das ist so ein bisschen so der Hintergrund vor dieser Unterhauswahl.
Warum hat es jetzt im Juli stattgefunden?
Weil eigentlich, wir haben so gehört aus Regierungskreisen, dass Rishi Sunak
wollte das. Er hat so gedacht, okay, ich denke, wir haben jetzt die besten Chancen.
Keine Ahnung, wie er so das gedacht hat.
Es ist ein bisschen mal wieder dieses fehlende politische Verständnis von ihm.
Aus meiner Sicht, das hat er total falsch kalkuliert. Ja, aber natürlich,
wenn er gewartet hätte bis Oktober, wären die Chancen dann auch höher,
bin ich auch nicht sicher.
Also das ist so ein bisschen so dem Hintergrund vor dieses Unterhauswahl.
Bevor wir vielleicht auf Leber kommen, also...
Lib Dems, die hat man ja nicht so richtig auf dem Zeiger. Sollte jetzt wirklich
dieser Fall eintreten, dass die mehr Sitze erhalten als die Tories,
dann hätte das ja nicht nur so rein von den Zahlen her Konsequenzen,
sondern dann wäre ja sozusagen Lib Dem auch das erste Mal so Leader of the Opposition,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also in diesem ganzen Parlaments hin und her,
man kennt das ja immer so, die eine Seite, die andere Seite,
man antwortet dem Prime Minister und das wird ja dann immer von dem Oppositionsführer,
das wären dann halt die Lib Dems geführt.
Das wäre ja dann sozusagen ein absolutes Novum, weil gab es das überhaupt irgendwann
mal, dass nicht Labour und Tories sich primär gegenüberstanden?
Also es gab Situationen in den so Jahren vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg,
also vor die jetzige parteipolitische Situation,
das käme damals zustande, es gab so National Unity Government.
Aber seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, nein, das gab kein einziges Mal.
Es gab natürlich zwischen 2010 und 2015 die Koalitionsregierung zwischen den
Liberalen und den Konservativen, aber dann war Labour die Hauptoppositionspartei.
Also dann Prime Ministers Question Time war immer konservativer Premierminister
und Labour war dann Oppositionspartei oder umgekehrt.
Es kam nie zustande, dass das Leader of the Opposition von irgendeiner anderen
Partei war in diesen kompletten Nachkriegsjahren. Und,
Wir haben mal wieder gesehen, dass die Liberalen eine regionale Stärke haben,
besonders im Südwesten.
Die haben auch ziemlich wenig zu Brexit gesagt, obwohl alle wissen,
dass hauptsächlich die sind die pro-europäischste Partei.
Aber die wussten, dass die müssen wieder eine Unterstützung,
besonders unter Bauern, bekommen in den ländlichen Regionen.
Also die haben dann wie immer ein ordentliches diszipliniertes Wahlkampf geführt
und können dann diese so alten Hartlands der Partei, also aus 2010,
die haben viele Wahlkreise in Devon und Somerset im Südwesten gewonnen.
Also ja, da gibt es dann eine gewisse Hoffnung, dass die da gewinnen.
Und dann auch in diese Pendlergürt von London.
Also da werden die auch diese ziemlich reichen Vororten von London auch da ziemlich
gut punkten, weil die Partei versucht nicht überall richtig zu kämpfen,
sondern fokussiert auf 50 oder 70 Wahlkreise.
Und das wird dann zu einem ordentlichen Ergebnis für die Partei führen.
Es gab ja in den ganzen Brexit-Wirren zwischendurch mal so Konstellationen,
wo es durchaus ja hätte sein können,
dass wenn sich die Opposition richtig zusammenführt, dass so Lib Dems und Grüne
und Labour quasi sich zusammentun und dann irgendwie vielleicht knapp die Tories überstimmen könnten.
Und dann war ja auch immer viel in der Diskussion, dass in dem Moment,
wo die Lib Dems ihr Gewicht mit reinwerfen, dass eine Bedingung sein könnte,
dann danach auch mal das Wahlsystem anzufassen.
Ja, aber irgendwie, das schwankte so schnell während einer sehr kurzen Periode.
Also 2019 gab es dann, auch als Starmer-Parteivorsitzender der Labour-Partei
geworden ist, hey Moment mal, das war ein bitteres Ergebnis,
eine 80-Sitz-Mehrheit für die Konservativen, also ein sehr stabiles Ergebnis.
Zudem, damals war die Rede, Moment mal, ganz vorsichtig vorangehen,
wir müssen damit aufpassen, dass wir überhaupt gewinnen können in 2024 oder 2025. 25.
Inzwischen und jetzt seit 18 Monaten, also die Konservativen sanken so rasant
in den Meinungsumfragen und Labour stieg so stark,
dass es war dann schon vor 18 Monaten war dann die Rede im Moment,
weil also warum brauchen wir so einen Kompromiss zwischen diesen progressiven
Parteien, weil Labour ist sowieso schon stark genug, ja, aber es,
Irgendwie dieses so früh gesetzene Unterhauswahl, jetzt im Juli statt im Oktober,
hat auch irgendwie den Liberalen geholfen, weil nicht alle Wahlkreise hatten
die Kandidaten schon bereit.
Also manche Parteien mussten ziemlich schnell irgendeinen Kandidaten irgendwo dann finden.
Und das bedeutet, dass die Parteien waren nicht überhaupt in der Lage,
ein ordentliches Wahlkampf überall zu führen.
Also obwohl es fehlte dann ein formelles Kompromiss zwischen Labour,
die Liberalen und die Grünen.
Informell ist es klar, dass Labour macht in 20, 40 Wahlkreisen,
wo die Liberalen stark sind, Labour macht da ziemlich wenig Wahlkampf.
Also hinter den Kulissen, hey Moment mal, da haben wir keine Chance,
da lassen wir die Liberalen gegen die Konservativen gewinnen.
Also keine formelle Einigung auf der höchsten Ebene, aber hinter den Kulissen schon ein bisschen.
Also das kommt doch zustande. Aber wir werden keine Reform der Wahlsysteme sehen
nach der Wahl, weil warum hat Labour ein solches Interesse?
Die haben so enorm gewonnen, die werden, wenn die enorm dann gewinnen,
die werden auch ein zweites Amt seit, vermutlich dann auch gewinnen,
Ende dieses Jahrzehnts.
Und mal wieder sind wir in dieser ganzen gleichen Situation wie unter Blair.
Also Labour ist an der Macht, hat dann plötzlich kein Interesse an Wahlreform mehr.
Obwohl ja die Tories dann durchaus ein Interesse daran haben könnten,
wenn sie jetzt sozusagen mit dieser Reformpartei oder irgendeiner potenziellen
weiteren Nachfolgepartei am rechten Rand sozusagen überhaupt gar nicht mehr in der Lage sind,
diese relevante Mehrheit zu organisieren.
Ja, aber die werden dann mal denken, nee, Moment mal, also wir bauen mal wieder
eine vereinigte Partei.
Stell dir vor, dass die Konservativen kriegen 100 Sitze und Reform 12.
Die machen dann einen Zusammenschluss, diese beiden Parteien, danach.
Sie drängen dann die Konservativen weiterhin nach rechts.
Und so wird es dann sein.
Dieses Denken auf der rechten Seite des politischen Spektrums,
es gibt nur eine Partei. Vielleicht temporär zwei.
Und dass die vereint sein sollen,
wird mittelfristig für die Konservativen wichtiger als egal was für eine Ideologie
die dann Richtung haben.
Also was bei uns Koalitionen sind, ist im angelsächsischen System eigentlich
immer mehr so die Internalisierung, wie man das ja auch in den USA sieht.
Jaja, man internalisiert diese Kompromisse.
Und das ist ein Problem für die Konservativen gerade, weil die externalisieren das gerade.
Aber meine Vermutung ist, nach der Unterhauswahl werden die dann versuchen,
es werden dann Leute sagen, hey, wir bringen Farage wieder ins Boot.
Aber natürlich, das bringt auch dann für die Konservativen auch Probleme,
weil das macht es dann noch schwieriger, diese eher weltoffene,
aber reiche Wahlkreise im Südosten England zu gewinnen mittelfristig.
Weil dieses Ära der von den Schichten der Gesellschaft geprägten Wahlsystem,
dass die Arbeiter wählen für Labour und die Mittelschicht wählt für die Konservativen,
das ist noch schwächer als je zuvor.
Weil es gibt so viele diverse Tendenzen, was für einen Bildungshintergrund man
hat, Leute aus diversen ethnischen Minderheiten, wo man wohnt,
in einer Stadt oder auf dem Land, diese regionalen Aspekte in Schottland oder in Wales.
Also dieses alte Zwei-Parteien-System ist sehr schwach geworden.
Und zum Beispiel Labour wird dieses Mal mehr oder weniger genau dem gleichen
Prozentsaal der abgegebenen Stimmen bekommen wie 97 unter Blair,
aber enorm viel mehr Wahlkreise gewinnen als damals.
Also dieses First-Past-the-Post-Wahl-System bedeutet, dass...
Das deckt diese tiefgehenden Probleme ab irgendwie.
Also es wird das wenigst proportionale Wahlergebnis aller Zeiten.
Also das Unterschied zwischen dem Prozentzahl der abgegebenen Stimmen und was
für ein Prozentzahl der Sitze man gewinnt.
Aber natürlich, das Kritik daran wird sehr begrenzt sein, weil es sind alle
Leute, die für eine Wahlreform sind, sind hauptsächlich links und Und die linke Seite wird gewinnen.
Also das bedeutet, dass die Konservativen werden dank dieses Systems dieses
Mal deutlich verlieren.
Aber ich sehe keine große Bewegung auf der rechten Seite des politischen Spektrums für Wahlreform.
Das käme nie zustande und wird dieses Mal auch nicht zustande kommen.
Also dieses demokratische Problem ist dringender als je zuvor.
Aber die Debatte wird, meine Vermutung, wird nicht wirklich stattfinden nach der Wahl.
Gut, dann kommen wir doch mal auf Labour. Man redet immer über alle,
aber nicht über die, die jetzt eigentlich gewinnen werden.
Labour hatte ja eine schwierige Zeit mit Corbyn als Vorgänger von Kirstein,
der dann irgendwann so unpopulär wurde. Ich glaube, da war dann noch der ein
oder andere Skandal. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, worum es ging.
Auf jeden Fall wurde ja dann Corbyn abgelöst.
Corbyn selber macht auf mich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, so ein bisschen wie
die Sarah Wagenknecht Großbritanniens.
Ist ja dann auch sagen wir mal mit seiner Haltung gegenüber Israel und so weiter
sehr problematisch gewesen jetzt ist halt Kirstama vor, was war das, vor 2-3 Jahren.
4 Jahre als Nachfolger gewählt worden und der ist ja ein sehr moderater Mensch
sag ich mal, der jetzt nicht durch laute Stimme auffällt,
wovon Also gehen wir jetzt mal davon aus, Labour wird morgen gewinnen.
Ich denke, das ist relativ offensichtlich.
Das heißt, wir werden eine Labour-only-Regierung haben, die wird eine sehr große
Mehrheit im Parlament haben. Kirst Dahmer wird Ministerpräsident.
Wir haben schon gehört, was sich irgendwie alles nicht ändern wird.
So die Außenpolitik, denke ich mal, das ist alles, wird mit Kontinuität strahlen.
Aber was kann Labour innenpolitisch, also was muss Labour innenpolitisch machen
und was werden sie auch innenpolitisch machen und vor allem,
was wird sich im Verhältnis zu Europa vielleicht ändern? dann?
Also innenpolitisch, es geht alles um,
Steuern und Finanzen hauptsächlich. Steuereinnahmen müssen erhört werden,
um die Lücken in den staatlichen Finanzen zu füllen.
Es gibt zur Zeit diversen Streiks oder Streitigkeiten mit zum Beispiel alle,
die in dem sozialen Sektor arbeiten, also Sozialhelfer.
Es gibt Spannungen zwischen den Ärzteverbänden und der Regierung.
Die Ärzte müssen zu lange arbeiten und wollen auch mehr Geld.
Das Problem ist unter den Konservativen, wo kommt das Geld dann her?
Die Frage ist, was für Steuererhöhungen sind dann möglich? Und dann wird es
den neuen Haushalt erst im Herbst dieses Jahr geben.
Wie sollen diese erhöhten Ausgaben dann überhaupt finanziert?
Weil natürlich man will Mehrwertsteuer und Einkommenssteuer nicht erhöhen,
aber man muss irgendwie diese Lücken füllen,
weil die Staatsschulden sind gestiegen während dieser konservativen Regierung.
Es gibt so Diskussionen über eine Erhöhung der Vermögenssteuer,
eine Sondersteuer auf privaten Schulen zum Beispiel wird gerade debattiert,
weil privaten Schulen, man muss keine Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen.
Auf die School Fees für privaten Schulen, also da soll eine Steuer erhoben worden.
Also das sind die hauptsächlichen sehr schwierigen Fragen für die ersten Monate
von einer Kirstamer Regierung.
Zweitens, es gibt diesen Niedriglohnsektor in Großbritannien,
den sogenannten Zero-Hours-Contracts.
Also das sind dann Arbeitsverträge, wo man verpflichtet ist,
für einen Arbeitgeber zu arbeiten und nicht für einen zweiten oder dritten Arbeitgeber.
Aber man hat keine Garantie, jede Woche irgendwelche Arbeitsstunden zu bekommen.
Also das sind so flexible Arbeitsverträge, die dann sehr, sehr hilfreich sind
für die Arbeitgeber, nicht für die Arbeitnehmer.
Und da wird eine Diskussion dann stattfinden, wie können wir das anders gestalten,
damit wir dann mehr Arbeitsrechte einführen können in dieses so niedrig Lohnsektor,
in den Service Industries,
also Restaurants und Kneipen, Supermärkte, diese Arten von Industrien.
Also das ist sehr hoch auf der Agenda von der Labour-Partei.
Bezüglich Außenpolitik, da erwarte ich sehr, sehr wenig, also besonders bezüglich
der Ukraine, kurz bis mittelfristig ist es faktisch gar nichts.
Also keine Änderungen.
Keine Änderungen, also genau die gleiche Linie.
Der möglichst zukünftige Außenminister David Lamy ist ein bisschen so am Rande
der Partei, ein klüger Typ, selber sehr pro-europäisch.
Aber begrenzt sind, was er machen kann.
Auch ein sehr wichtiges Punkt, der Energieminister wird vermutlich Ed Miliband
sein, also der ehemalige Parteichef der Labour-Partei aus dem Jahr 2010 bis 2015.
Und die wollen dann einen Bruchteil der Energieversorgung in Großbritannien
dann nationalisieren, also verstaatlichen und auch einen Teil der Bahnindustrie auch verstaatlichen.
Also alte Labour-Politik-Felder.
Also diese Liberalisierung funktionierte nicht, sagen die.
Also wir wollen diese Teile der Wirtschaft dann mittelfristig verstaatlichen.
Also nicht von einem Tag bis zum nächsten, aber mittelfristig schon.
Also bezüglich EU, da habe ich keine großen Erwartungen.
Also erstens, dieses Ton wird ruhiger.
Also man kann immer mit Starmer reden, man kann immer mit Lamy reden.
Also es werden keine Spannungen geben. Also das ist schon ein Plus.
Starmer hat selber gesagt, ja, es wäre nett, an diversen Treffen der EU-Außenminister
teilzunehmen, hat er mal vorgeschlagen vor ein paar Monaten.
Und dann kam das Antwort aus Brüssel, nein, lieber nicht.
Ihr seid ausgestiegen, warum wollen wir das überhaupt? Ihr bleibt doch noch am Rande.
Ich erwarte Diskussionen zu Lebensmittelstandards, so einer Phytosanitary Agreement
zwischen Brüssel und Großbritannien, damit man muss dann für den Import und
Export von Lebensmitteln,
dass keine Kontrollen dann überhaupt erforderlich seien.
Also sowas könnte Labour dann tatsächlich machen. Aber das würde auch bedeuten.
Dass UK dann auch akzeptieren, die europäischen Standards wieder akzeptieren müsste.
Ja, also was noch tatsächlich der Fall ist.
Also Labour könnte das doch machen, also ohne große Sorgen.
Was ich nicht erwarte ist ein Wiedereintritt in den Binnenmarkt oder in die Soll-Union.
Da hat Labour kein Interesse, die britische Wirtschaft schon. Warum nicht?
Die sagt, es war ein Fehler mit Brexit.
Aber alle kämpfen um die Pro-Brexit-Fehler. Also.
Also in den Großstädten, wo Labour sowieso gewinnt, was für einen Vorteil bringt
das, wenn Labour sagt, die wollen eine Annäherung an Brüssel?
Keinelei, weil die gewinnen sowieso. Die Liberalen ebenfalls.
Alle wissen, dass die grundsätzlich pro-europäisch sind, aber die müssen in
diese Pendlergurt von London gewinnen, in ehemalige konservative Wahlkreise.
Die Konservativen sind eh für den Brexit, also wollen kein besseres Verhältnis zu Brüssel.
Das ist dann nur die Grünen und die sind ja dann sehr klein die werden vielleicht
diesmal ein paar Wahlkreise mehr gewinnen vielleicht in Bristol gewinnen die aber das bedeutet,
dass obwohl Labour und die Liberalen ein bisschen pro-europäischer sind unter
den Mitgliedern, sogar unter den Wählern, die haben keinerlei Interesse das
zu sagen während dieses Wahlkampf also dass niemand debattiert Brexit während dieses Wahlkampf,
keinerlei und das kann ich irgendwie aus taktischen Gründen verstehen.
Aber wie blöd ist das, dass man hat dann eine Unterhauswahl,
sollen die Probleme des Landes dann irgendwie halbwegs lösen und ein Kernproblem
wird nicht gelöst aus taktischen Gründen.
Und ja, aber so ist das.
Also Labour sagt nichts zum Thema Brexit, die Liberalen auch nicht,
die Konservativen nicht, Reform von Farage schon, aber aber die sind eigentlich
so die Brexit-Radikale.
Aber heißt das, dass du jetzt Kirst Dahmer auch nicht zutraust,
so ein bisschen aus sich selbst herauszukommen?
Nee, nee, keinerlei. Und die Leute um ihn, besonders die ...
Die finanzpolitische Sprecherin gerade, Rachel Reeves, sie ist sehr,
sehr konservativ, kommt auch aus eines von diesen nordenglischen Wahlkreisen, wo vorher,
also sie hat nicht in Leeds, am Rande von Leeds ist der Wahlkreis von Reeves.
Sie hat selber nicht verloren 2019, aber die Konservativen waren ziemlich nah dran da.
Und sie sagt, hey, also meine Wähler, die haben ja Angst, also wir müssen einen
Erfolg aus dem Brexit machen. Und Wes Streeting, der Gesundheitssprecher der Partei.
Die sind nicht Leute, die irgendeine Überzeugung haben.
Die haben überhaupt eine Ideologie. Die sind natürlich fähiger und klüger und
weniger korrupt als die Konservativen.
Aber wofür steht eine zukünftige Labour-Partei?
Okay, wir tun ja was für dieses Mindestlohnsektor, wir tun ja was für die Gesundheitsversorgung.
Aber was will, was für eine Zukunft des Landes stellt Leber vor?
Also haben wir wenig Ahnung.
Oder Klimaschutz.
Niemand hat darüber geredet in diesem Wahlkampf.
Ja, es ist alles so sehr miserabel, so das Horizont ist so runter irgendwie.
Oje, ich hatte die Hoffnung, dass jetzt so eine große Mehrheit dann vielleicht
auch ein bisschen Ruhe schafft, dass man sich dann doch vielleicht mal um das
ein oder andere kümmern könnte, was vielleicht mal relevant ist.
Ja, aber niemand, das Dame selber traut sich nicht, irgendwas...
Zu sagen oder vorzuschlagen.
Er hat so Angst, dass Labour könnte trotz allem dann noch verlieren. irgendwie,
das kommt durch den kompletten Wahlkampf. Kein Risiko, nicht sagen,
don't promise anything,
under promise and over deliver, ist so die Rede.
Aber wenn die Regierung immer nur Selbstzweck ist, dann kommt man ja nie zum
Regieren. Also ich meine, warum will man in einer Regierung sein,
wenn man in einer Regierung sowieso nichts ändern will?
Also das ist ja dann irgendwie auch, dann kann man es ja auch gleich bleiben lassen.
Und das Unterschied, intellektuell, man könnte sagen, diese ganze Third Way,
die neue Mitte von Blair und Schröder damals, also so ein bisschen mit Blick zurück,
das war zum Teil Schwachsinn.
Aber man hatte irgendeine Ahnung, wie soll Großbritannien dann tatsächlich funktionieren.
Man hatte Leute, die intellektuell interessant waren, rund um Blair,
Peter Mandelson, Gordon Brown, Robin Cook, Mo Mowlam.
Diese waren sehr, sehr interessante Menschen, die Ideen haben für die Zukunft des Landes.
Vielleicht nicht alle diese Ideen stimmten, aber die waren fähige Menschen mit
Ideen und das haben wir gerade keinerlei.
Also was ist denn, wie heißt der Typ von LSE, Anthony Giddens,
also der was so den intellektuellen Rotfaden durch den ersten vier bis sechs
Jahren der Labour-Regierung von Blair,
was ist den intellektuellen Faden durch den jetzigen Labour-Partei,
gibt es ja überhaupt eine?
Wenn ja, ich habe es, ich kenne es nicht.
Ja, okay.
Tja, die wirklich interessanten Intellektuellen, die machen jetzt irgendwie
Podcasts, habe ich so den Eindruck und beteiligen sich nicht mehr so richtig
an der ganzen Diskussion.
Also zum Beispiel hier, du kennst vielleicht hier, The Rest is Politics mit
Alastair Campbell und Rory Stewart.
Sehr interessanter Blick auf die Welt und halt auch beide so,
also Alastair Campbell war damals glaube ich der Berater von Tony Blair, so die rechte Hand.
Rory Stewart hat mir glaube ich auch mal diskutiert im Rahmen von Brexit,
weil er ja unter anderem auch angetreten ist Nachfolger zu werden,
hat er natürlich gegen Boris Johnson verloren,
aber es sind beides sehr interessante Leute von sozusagen beiden Seiten der
Politik, die sich jetzt im Podcast zusammengefunden haben.
Finde ich immer wieder sehr interessant, wie die, also die britische und auch
die internationale Politik analysieren, aber so eine Leute fehlen halt jetzt an der Front sozusagen.
Also es ist einfach kein intellektuelles Spiel mehr.
Ja, und also hinter den Kulissen gibt es ein paar Namen.
So Morgan McSweeney, der ist der Kampagnenchef, Datenanalytiker der Labour-Partei,
also um zu gucken, wie bildet man Mehrheiten.
Sue Gray ist so der Head of Staff von Starmer, also quischt so alles auf der
Reihe, damit alles ordentlich bleibt.
Ähm, ja, ähm, aber, ja, so, wer spielt so den Alastair Campbell Rolle?
Ja, ähm, das ist nicht klar, ob es so jemanden geben wird, ja.
Ähm, ja, ähm, ich hab leider keine, keine Antworten.
Was denkst du, wie sich eine Labour-Regierung und speziell Keir Starmer gegenüber
den USA verhalten würden wenn
jetzt tatsächlich der Trump Effekt nochmal eintritt ich hoffe es ja nicht.
Aber man muss ja damit rechnen weil als Person Trump ist alles was Starmer nicht
ist also die Starmer mit Joe Biden Die kommen auf jeden Fall super gut klar.
Die sind beide nicht sehr ideologisch, sehr pragmatisch, haben so ein langes Sicht.
Also das wird auf jeden Fall super locker sein.
Ich bin auch sicher, dass irgendein Staatsbesuch oder so, vielleicht nicht vor
der Wahl in den Vereinigten Staaten, aber irgendwie irgendwas wird bestimmt organisiert.
Keine Sorge. Mit Trump, also ich kann es überhaupt nicht verstehen,
wie die miteinander klarkommen.
Der Stammerwert, der war Jurist, der ist ein bisschen langweilig, der ist...
Desruhig zu den persönlichen Verhältnissen.
Ich kann es kaum glauben, wie die miteinander in einem Raum sitzen.
Also das wird sehr, sehr schwierig sein.
Auch Lamy, der Außenpolitische Sprecher der Labour-Partei, kommt mit denen überhaupt nicht klar.
Also es werden enorme persönlichen Spannungen geben.
Natürlich wird Starmer ruhig bleiben und sagen, ja, ich baue Brücken,
NATO ist wichtig für uns.
Ja, also, das wird natürlich Starmer schrittweise näher an die EU dann drücken, falls Trump gewinnt.
Aber die persönlichen Verhältnisse, Die werden sehr, sehr schwierig sein.
Aber was ich nicht erwarte, ist
dann öffentliche Kritik von Starmer an irgendwas in den Freien Staaten.
Die sind unsere historischen Alliierten.
Wir werden, egal wer in dem White House sitzt, werden wir mit ihm arbeiten.
Das wird so die Rede sein.
Aber es könnte natürlich vielleicht Großbritannien nochmal näher wiederum an
Europa heranbringen, oder?
Ja, das stimmt, aber nur sehr langsam, so schrittweise.
Einige Intellektuelle in The Guardian werden bestimmt mal sagen, okay,
jetzt müssen wir Großbritannien, wir müssen jetzt, falls Trump dann gewinne,
müssen wir jetzt eine Entscheidung treffen, was ist jetzt unsere Rolle?
Dann beginnt vielleicht dann
tatsächlich eine etwas tiefgehende Debatte in Richtung Großbritannien.
Aber das erwarte ich dann erst nach einer Wahl von Trump im November.
Ja, jetzt haben wir eigentlich, glaube ich, alles ganz gut zusammengefasst,
was bisher so passiert ist. Hast du noch ein paar ausgehende Hoffnungen oder
könnte irgendwas noch anders kommen?
Also, was ist dann zu erwarten Donnerstagabend und Freitagfrüh?
Weil Wahlabende sind ziemlich spannend in Großbritannien. Also,
weil man wählt am Donnerstag, die Urnen sind bis 22 Uhr britischer Zeit offen,
also 23 Uhr deutsche Zeit.
Und dann, man muss dann den Wahlabend auf BBC News oder auf Sky News dann folgen.
Und die werden dann die ersten Exit-Polls, und die sind normalerweise in Großbritannien ziemlich genau.
Und die werden dann messen eine Anzahl an möglichen Sitzen für die jeweiligen Parteien.
Die Schwankungen sind diesmal etwas höher als in vorherigen Wahlen,
weil man nicht so genau weiß, was ist die Rolle von Reform,
also dieser rechtspolitische Bewegung von Nigel Farage.
Also die Erwartungen von der Anzahl an Sitzen, dann schwanken sehr,
sehr viel vergleichsweise,
weil es die höchste Anzahl an Wahlkreisen, die es je gab,
die dann plus oder minus drei Prozent sind, so stehen auf der Kippe.
Also das bedeutet, das macht das Wahlabend im Voraus für die Meinungsforscher ziemlich schwierig.
Die Frage ist dann, was ist dann die Anzahl an Sitzen, die die Konservativen
gewinnen? Das ist eine sehr, sehr wichtige Zahl.
In den Meinungsumfragen schwankt das gerade.
Zwischen 53 und 155 werden die dann gewinnen.
Das bedeutet, gewinnen die eine Menge Wahlkreise dann ziemlich knapp oder verlieren
die eine Menge Wahlkreise dann sehr knapp.
Die Anzahl an Sitzen für Labour, also es ist ganz, ganz klar,
das können wir jetzt mit ziemlich genauer Sicherheit sagen, dass es wird ein
historischer Wahlabend sein für Labour.
Die werden mehr Sitze gewinnen als im Jahr 97.
Die Frage ist einfach nur, wie viele. Und Labour hat...
146 neue Wahlkreise gewonnen im Jahr 97.
Die Schätzungen diesmal sind für ein Plus von Labour von zwischen 180 und 285
neue Wahlkreise werden von der Labour-Partei dann gewinnen.
Also die werden bei einer überragenden Mehrheit dann landen.
Die anderen Fragen sind, kriegen die Liberalen genug Sitze, damit die dann die
offizielle Opposition sind.
Also ich halte das für eher unwahrscheinlich, aber könnte bei einem so Horrorabend
für die Konservativen, ist es tatsächlich möglich.
In Schottland ist dann die Frage, landet die SNP noch als größte Partei bei
der Sitzverteilung oder überholt lebe dann auch da die SNP.
Und wir werden vermutlich so 1 Uhr morgens, dann am Freitagmorgen,
die ersten Ergebnisse aus den wichtigen Wahlkreisen dann tatsächlich bekommen.
Und dann bis so 3, 4 Uhr morgens wird es dann klar, wer da dann überhaupt,
oder die Ausmaßen der Verluste für die Konservativen.
Aber das ist so grob meine Vermutung. Labour gewinnt, ein historischer Verlust
für die Konservativen und dann eine eher geringe Chance,
dass die Liberalen dann die zweitgrößte Partei in dem Unterhaus sind.
Die Farage-Bewegung, die werden zwischen 1 und 20 Sitzen gewinnen bei 10% der
abgegebenen Stimmen. Die Grünen kriegen vielleicht zwei oder drei.
Und dann in Schottland die Frage, ist S&P oder Labour da die größte Partei?
Also das sind so ein paar Prognosen vor dem Wahlabend.
Alle, die das jetzt hören, können das relativ bald oder bereits jetzt schon
überprüfen, wenn man mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
Gut, John, ich glaube an der Stelle können wir dann den Sack zumachen.
Klar.
Was machen wir jetzt mit der Brexit-Nachlese? Das Kapitel ist jetzt ein bisschen
abgeschlossen, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Das ist jetzt geschlossen. Und auch, ich erwarte keine großen Änderungen von der Labour-Partei.
Auch in Bezug zwischen Starmer und der Europäischen Kommission und Starmer und Olaf Scholz.
Es wird alles ziemlich ruhig sein. Also, falls irgendwas stattfindet,
machen wir dann wieder einen Podcast zum Thema Brexit.
Aber kurz- bis mittelfristig, ich erwarte keine großen Änderungen.
Und ich bin auch selber größtenteils aus diesem Themenfeld auch ausgestiegen.
Es gibt ziemlich wenig zu analysieren zum Thema Großbritannien, EU.
EU und nach diesem so Horror-Jahrzehnt ist es nicht vielleicht für alle gut,
dass es nicht zu den alltäglichen Diskussionen gehört.
Ja, falls es quasi irgendwas auftaucht, dann machen wir dann erneut einen Podcast,
aber ich habe keinerlei Erwartungen, dass es große Änderungen geben wird zum
Thema Brexit in den nächsten paar Jahren.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns irgendwann mal über Züge unterhalten,
und da bist du ja jetzt sehr viel mehr in dem Thema drin.
Gut, aber dann sage ich an der Stelle nochmal vielen Dank, auch für die gesamte
Begleitung über die Jahre und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war es hier bei
UKW. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.